welcome to the man of recaps this is the
walking dead season 11 episode 10. at
the end of episode 9 the commonwealth
finally came to alexandria and offered
everyone to join them the episode ended
with a six-month time jump showing daryl
as a stormtrooper fighting maggie at the
hilltop but now we're going back to see
how we got there we are just one month
into most of our crew joining the
commonwealth it's halloween and they're
throwing a big festival maybe the zombie
haunted house is in poor taste but
besides that things in the commonwealth
are great it's more than a survivor's
community like alexandria was it's like
a real-life normal pre-apocalyptic city
and now we finally get to meet the
leader of the commonwealth governor
pamela milton she seems like a good
leader but our crew doesn't have a great
track record with governors our gang is
settling into their new commonwealth
jobs based on their skills like king
ezekiel's the zookeeper again and
carol's bacon cookies connie is a
reporter apparently she was a big shot
reporter before the zombie apocalypse
daryl and rosita excellent fighters are
joining the commonwealth military
they're way too advanced for basic
training they are zombie-killing experts
but this exercise wasn't just about them
killing the rotters which is what the
commonwealth calls walkers it was about
working together as a team and daryl the
lone wolf did not pass then they go for
a special mission with pamela milton's
son sebastian milton as we remember from
earlier this season he is an annoying
spoiled joffrey baratheon douchebag as
the crown prince of the commonwealth
he's out here getting some one-on-one
rotter slang training with mercer head
of security but daryl ruins his fun by
saving his life and gets sebastian mad
at him and mercer's like look man if you
want this job you gotta fit in now
normally daryl wouldn't need this job he
could just leave and go be a woods
hermit again but with rick and michonne
out of the picture daryl's the adopted
father of two kids now judith and rj
right now they're living in a crappy
apartment they're broke daryl needs that
stormtrooper salary to provide for his
family yes that is the secretly evil
part of the commonwealth much like the
world before the apocalypse it's all
about money and we've got a massive
wealth gap here while the upper class
has fancy parties drinking wine the
lower class is not so much yumiko who
was a harvard grad high powered lawyer
before is part of this inner circle
while her former girlfriend and best
friend magna is a waitress by the way
yumiko's brother is part of the upper
class now too they've got him working as
a surgeon again but he doesn't like it
he was happier as a simple baker
speaking of surgery ezekiel needs some
for his throat cancer but carol does
some classic carol snooping around and
finds out he's way down the list yeah
they don't care he was royalty in the
zombie apocalypse before the fall he was
a zookeeper not important but carol did
some more snooping around and overheard
that lance hornsby needs better quality
wine for the party tonight and
resourceful as ever carol's already
found a way to sneak outside the walls
she goes to a nearby mansion with a wine
cellar and after a little zombie fight
comes back with a real nice vintage
she's like hey in exchange i want
ezekiel moved up that surgery list and
lance hornsby's impressed he's like
carol you and me gonna do some good work
together and by the way as for carol and
ezekiel's relationship remember they
were married for the whole six-year time
jump but then broke up after they
adopted son henry's death but now they
seem to be back together at least a
little bit another former royal princess
also finds herself in the lower class
now but she's got an in with the general
mercer they still kind of like each
other but now governor milton's fancy
party is disrupted by a disgruntled
worker he takes her assistant hostage
like we are the 99 he runs out of there
and it's a big man hunt it's daryl who
finds him sorry man but you're under
arrest sebastian milton was right behind
him though and daryl's like hey let's
say you caught this guy you take the
glory and i'll score some points with
you so this guy's going to jail but he's
like hey i'm the first of many we're
starting a worker's revolution and
pamela milton does not like that
rosita's tasked with interrogating the
wait staff pitting her against magna
will our group be split up on opposite
sides of this revolution for now a few
days later after helping out sebastian
milton daryl's made a full-on
stormtrooper and got a nicer apartment
for his family but they're not fighting
zombies right now their main task is to
root out this potential workers
conspiracy and rosita finds a secret
room with all sorts of like graffiti and
stuff including this one that kind of
looks like heisenberg from breaking bad
so get ready for some class warfare in
the commonwealth and that's where
episode 10 comes to an end
hit that subscribe button for more of
the best recaps of tvn movies and check
out the join button to support the
channel as a member